Ted to is directed by Seth MacFarlane
and stars Mark Wahlberg Amanda Seyfried
and Seth MacFarlane as Ted the bear as
we learned in the first film that little
bear was wished to life by Mark Wahlberg
as a child and now he's married but he's
still a stoner who just hangs around
with Mark Wahlberg all day the plot
behind this movie is that people are now
challenging Ted's right to be a person
to have a job to be married to have
human rights and civil rights and so he
has to go to court to try to prove that
he is actually a person despite being
property officially labeled by the
government and Amanda Seyfried plays
their lawyer who's trying to help them
prove this so they set out on an
adventure involving tons of weed and
farts and it's Ted too now I actually
enjoyed the first Ted I thought it was a
very fresh movie there wasn't really
anything like it I had ever seen a guy
whose buddies with a talking bear who
likes to curse a lot I mean I had never
seen anything like that before
and Mark Wahlberg really surprised me in
that movie and once again he's really
great hear him in Seth MacFarlane have
great chemistry you really believe their
over-the-top relationship you totally
believe everything that comes out of
their mouths and despite the fact that
Seth MacFarlane is basically doing the
Peter Griffin voice as a bear he still
works really well as the Ted character
that being said I didn't find this movie
nearly as funny as the first one it is
definitely better than McFarland's last
film a million ways to die in the West
which was just really bad this is
definitely better than that movie it's
definitely funnier it has more jokes
there's a lot of jokes that hit however
similar to the first film the third act
gets really bloated with this gigantic
action scene it gets all serious just
like in the first head and just like the
first one it starts to get really
dragged out in fact is even a part where
Mark Wahlberg looks around it's like hey
man I'm having deja vu here I like the
idea of the set piece they construct at
the end in this movie there's wasn't
really that much to it it was just a lot
of ball hits and slapstick stuff that
could have been a lot more entertaining
than it was and that unnecessarily
serious backstory just weighed the movie
down because you go to these comedies
you just want to laugh but what worked
for me about Ted too was the interesting
camaraderie that forms between
Wahlberg's Seyfried and Ted these guys
all together actually formed a pretty
cool team and I like seeing them work
together there is definitely an
over-reliance on weed jokes I feel like
since pineapple express they're real
they aren't any more weed jokes that can
be made that haven't been made already
and there's a huge Jurassic Park joke in
this movie it didn't really work for me
because they end up directly quoting
lines from Jurassic Park they put them
into Ted too and they just don't fit in
they don't make any sense it just comes
off as we're repeating Jurassic Park
lines for no reason I don't want to
sound too overly negative here because
for the most part I found Ted to be a
pretty funny movie I think if you
enjoyed the first film you'll probably
have a good time with Ted too but there
isn't really anything hilariously
gut-busting amazing about this one there
were maybe two parts where I was really
laughing really hard the first Ted had
me laughing considerably harder and more
consistently in Ted too it's a lot of
the same with some good humor thrown in
and some interesting things to say about
human and civil rights in a Seth
MacFarlane movie which is a weird thing
to say I guess overall though I think if
you enjoyed the first Ted you're still
going to find things to like about this
one Wahlberg was good Seth MacFarlane as
Ted was good a man to Seyfried was good
there just wasn't really that much meat
to this movie it sort of felt like a
string of interesting little moments
sort of like Family Guy and it didn't
really pay off as much in the end it's
the first film did I'm going to give Ted
two C+ so if you've seen Ted to would
like to know your thoughts on it or Seth
MacFarlane humor in general because I
know he's very divisive he's very
polarizing some people hate him some
people love him I personally think
sometimes you can be really funny but
sometimes not so much and had to sort of
a mixed bag of both guys thank you so
much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes